but the show really didn't find itself
until the third season when they put us
on after cheers so suddenly they handed
us the biggest audience in tele are you
counting the third season you had the
four and then was four that was season
one pilot and four was season 1 13
mid-season replacement with season two
they had to give us a full season order
for in order to contractually get
everybody to do season 3 so they gave it
to us but they said well they actually
gave us the the first 18 the back on
hold but they said we're going to commit
to 18 or at least paying you for 18 and
they put us on after cheers and that's
that's when we finally had an audience
discover us and then we were pretty
smooth sailing after that when did you
realize or feel like oh my gosh I'm on a
a I remember the moment a
moment it was late in the third season
there we we already had started to put
up some numbers on the on the
ratings and I was I guess I was on
something like Entertainment Tonight and
they were in my neighborhood shooting
b-roll
and the b-roll was the reporter and I
walking down the sidewalk in my
neighborhood and as we were doing that a
van went by family in a van happened to
be a black family and a little girl that
I'm going to estimate was eight or nine
years old yelled out the window I love
you George and I went what the hell is
she watching how is she watching our
show this this show can't possibly
there's no love for her
show and I start that's when I started
to go oh I'm not aware of what's
Happening something's happening because
if this little girl is a watching our
show and finding anything in it to love
I don't quite understand my own show and
that's when I started to
think that I don't understand my own
show or I don't understand our audience
and that this phenomena was starting to
take over CU very few people have you
know it's amazing how many people
just want to be performers but you're an
elite you're in a very you're in a very
elite group of people that kind of made
it to the stratosphere and have made it
to the you really have and you are part
of pop culture and that's got to be an
an
interesting I I get very little of the
of the negative part of that um that
some of our colleagues can experience
when they when they hit that kind of
notor iety and um where the thing
they're doing becomes so big and
important and valuable in people's lives
sometimes that not variety can be an
extraordinary burden for them I I never
got the worst parts of
that